on this episode Stefan Indy and I wear
the same clothes I talk about drinking
and we're instagrams going
[Music]
yes
Carrie B hey everybody this is gary
vay-ner-chuk and this is episode 181 of
the ask gary vee show had a good solid
episode yesterday was good to get back
on the saddle first time we're going
back to back in a minute
what's up periscope good to see the
Aussies in the house looking forward to
our two-hour interview in a few minutes
good to see the actual book this was the
galley I kept showing you this is where
you send the people I guess it's not the
fully corrected book the actual book is
in place now look at this Kasey's look
at d-roc you must love this Casey's in
the back cover and my favorite part did
you get it the Iraqi good good my
favorite part the Jets t-shirt is on the
binding I gotta say I mean this I
actually wanted to see if we can pick up
can we like fine - Thank You economy and
crush it I'm curious if this is bigger I
feel like it's bigger than both of them
combined by the way the index I just
looked at I like that Yik yak is on page
155 and 171 to 172 Oh sucks made at page
170 sexually have abyss the crossword
this is gonna be interesting
first person to fill out the crossword
puzzle correctly and take a picture of
it and get it to me
wins something India you will yeah
what's been going on wow you made me eat
my words you feeling good stuff on you
contributed you got some video action
alright good I'm ready for the show I'm
feeling really really good actually yeah
oh by the way Boston looks locked and
loaded March 10th
I think night is it's been March 9th
sure you've got my phone give me your
calendar but you can get into the first
question in the end I wanna the 11th is
Friday so I was right right yes
March 10th boss Oh it'll be the night of
March 9th March 9th Boston locked and
loaded
we haven't locked loaded it yet I'm a
hundred percent doing a book event there
just got to find the person that's gonna
pony up five thousand
looks to host me or 3,500 or beggars
can't be choosers it might be 2700 will
say but it will happen Boston I'm coming
I'm wearing a Jets jersey and and I'm
ready to go alright let's do it
Patrick luckily any wait a minute what
this is a maroon explosion I'm very
proud of us we didn't even we didn't
even text each other in the morning like
we always do
181 is the maroon explosion alright
let's do it
Patrick Patrick asks hi man what do you
think about Instagram in the next two to
three years from now I think Instagram
will be easily one of the top two social
networks in America and globally will be
a major force I think that Facebook and
snapchat are the only two things that
compete with it and I think that anybody
who right now isn't spending a
disproportionate amount of time trying
to figure out the hashtag culture the
Instagram ad product your organic
Instagram posting working with Instagram
influencers is making a huge mistake to
not set their business up properly in a
2018-2019 world so massively bullish all
in it's one of the biggest reasons I
think all of you whether you could only
afford one share or a thousand shares I
think Facebook does extremely well
because of the revenue that we haven't
even seen the real revenue come in from
Instagram yet it's a beast it is the
current social network of the moment for
twenty eight to forty is Coast Americans
2020 to 235 other parts of America and I
just think it's an incredibly important
platform and I'm very very bullish on it
and as somebody who day trades attention
by the time by the way we have to write
my day trade attention article it's time
you know I think it's a massively
important time buying it now I don't
predict for two years but that's my
intuition and by the way here's a good
time to chop this indie rock show this
that Facebook why use Instagram Oh step
on Gary Vernon shake who's the
co-founder of vaynermedia back in
January predicting the purchase of
Instagram by Facebook and today Facebook
founder Mark Zuckerberg shelled out
billion dollars for that very service
that was when I was on the piers morgan
show on CNN the day Facebook bought
Instagram I made that comment and
everybody on Twitter said I was an idiot
because Instagram was only 500 days old
but sucks did fund him it was probably
worth 50 billion dollars right now maybe
more so when you buy for one you did
well
cuz those are billions you know it's not
just a 50x when you're 50 X 8 bucks it's
nice to have 400 bucks when you're 50 X
a billion that's that's 11 jets teams
yeah Patrick also yes Patrick asks if TV
is the radio and phone is the new TV
what is the desktop computer I'm not
sure yes I mean you know I can't just
give those kind of answers on the show
cuz there's so few answers ever in
history and who knows if I want to do an
askgaryvee book to the desktop you I
mean I think you know the TV the the TV
the radio
what's the desktop can become I don't
know like the biggest magazines and
print articles and night you know the
Wall Street Journal New York Times
Sports Illustrated and Time magazine in
1992 right like it was a major thing but
but the phone is just a proxy to the
Internet it's the delivery mechanism so
really you know what you know what
actually I got a much better one see
this is why I took it the desktop
computer or the laptop was the
black-and-white television the mobile
device is the color television because
they're both delivering the Internet
it's the Internet that is what I'm
talking about the phone just happens to
be the Telamon you know
like hey this is not the asking you show
you you can go do this with everybody
else after you can do what everybody
else does Ponder's we don't do that one
more time
well we don't to script the question
like so what is the next like desktop no
no no that's it what I think he was
asking for historical well will the
thrill' do you just think like will at
home is just like oh my call me the
thrill and try he's gonna get his boys
to call him the thrill will says hey
Gary what do you think is the best
market for a teenager to start selling
things it's the will instrument and
snapchat interim snapchat Instagram is
really happening I mean there are kids
on Instagram making Bank selling
sneakers like tens of that do you know
much money I would make if I was born
during this era if I was if I was 13 now
I expect to go to like the store and I
think I'm a licensed like and buy [ __ ]
and then flip [ __ ] like three weeks
later on a Saturday if I had real time
marketplace dynamics and I could buy
stuff
my poor I mean UPS and FedEx guy would
have been my homies stuff would've been
coming in and out like ridiculous um so
Instagram and snapchat because that's
where other teenagers are spending their
time and I do believe that most
teenagers best opportunity to sell [ __ ]
is to sell to other teenagers of course
they can sell to other demos but I think
the biggest upsides there and I only
know this you know the only reason
really it's why I answered Instagram so
quickly is I know dozens of kids dozens
which is a lot off the top of my dome of
kids making thousands of dollars
slinging sneakers and I just sneakers I
mean I've seen the video games cuz I
like that for you know old school video
games
there's a lot of opportunity instagrams
abby's for selling stuff Phillip asks
when you go out for some drinks how many
do you have
and still stay productive the next day
so let them drink them you know it's
funny I actually said this the other day
and in in a conversation in my life
which was I don't think I would have
ever drank alcohol just like you know a
lot of people reacted to the fact that
on the show the other day or somewhere a
daily view or whatever I said that you
know I've met
drugs I've never even smoked a cigarette
I don't think I would have ever drank
alcohol I didn't have my first beer
until I was 19
you know like and I'd probably drank
like 20 of them like I used to like talk
about milking a beer at like a party
like when you were 20 like my [ __ ] was
like not warm it was like a hot spring
you know like like I I don't really love
alcohol I learned to love wine I'm
really as weird i weirdly started liking
really well-made mixed drinks like the
bartender culture of New York helped
that so like bourbon things of that
nature like but I don't love alcohol so
what was the question of do have how
many drinks like once you know what
actually does get me drunk the last
three times I've been drunk sake I love
sushi sushi so much it's in such little
portions and usually when I have sushi
for some weird reason it's usually a
Friday or Saturday night and I'm usually
with Lizzie or very close friends and
some more relaxed and I go and Sachi
gives me gets be twisted but besides
that
thanks man I don't know so uh by the way
I'm right now I'm on a hardcore diet I
don't know if you guys have noticed but
I've got five pounds in last three weeks
I notice a little bit yeah yeah thank
you and so and so yeah I I really have
to say that nothing nothing really gets
me excited about drinking alcohol like
it's not something that's part of my
culture and so I'll bring a glass of
wine or two when I'm not in this
hardcore diet stuff and it's super easy
productive because that's you know I
grew up from 22 to 30 I was tasting a
hundred wines a day and my tolerance is
my tolerance is stunningly through the
roof
because of all that and so yeah they're
all drinks meetings but like last night
they were all like Seltzer with lemon
and lime was it for
I know that thank you Matt asks what are
your thoughts on employee retention in
the digital marketing industry is the
high turnover normal the reason there's
high turnover my industry agency life is
because most companies are owned by
holding companies so how are required so
there's four major holding companies in
advertising
they've consolidate and bought up all
the agencies and they're do these big
billion-dollar conglomerates and I don't
know everything about it cuz I haven't
really studied it but they're big
holding companies which tell companies
like vaynermedia great companies like 72
and sunny great digital shop and a TV
shop like deroga five just got so a
great company like these great cup 360 I
carrot that got bought by vice they're
owned by holding companies who tell
their CEOs got you know usually the guy
or gal that looks like me that's sold
the company for a lot of money to get
upfront but then you have to earn it out
and then you're locked in because half
your money is gonna come after four
years so you got to keep the job golden
handcuffs google it if you don't know
what I mean and so they tell them you
have to run your company at a twenty
seven percent gross margin where 23
percent course margin you know if I had
to do that tomorrow because I wanted the
big cash out I probably thought 5 or 100
people and then what happens is the
inevitable thing that looks like this
you know you have a superstar youngster
that's growing up within the
organization and we and you guys have
lived as so many have gone from you know
making very little to making more and
more and more right you inevitably don't
promote them for a year or two because
he can't afford to because the only rule
is you've got to make twenty three point
seven percent gross profit the only rule
and so the reason there's huge turnover
is because the best people don't get
compensated fast enough nobodies who run
nobody who's running the company has
long term ambitions because they've
already sold out and they're only trying
to stay there for three or four more
years and maximize their bonuses and
their money so they're making the
decision and it's like anything in life
everything stems from topic so I always
say on the show and I said yesterday
infront of the whole company everything
is my fault and that's true in these
scenarios and so this has been a huge
advantage for my company I'm able to do
what I'm doing because I want to build
an evergreen company forever and so I'm
able to treat I'm able to deploy
meritocracy and if that comes at my
expense
it comes in my short term expense but 15
years from now
and of happiness and financial I'll win
so that's why that's happening and they
burnt and so because they don't want to
pay and because they run a margin they
do a lot of things they don't compensate
people probably they leave they burn
good people to the ground you know you
know what goes on here I mean you're in
the trenches if somebody's had a hard
core account that's tough you know we
usually get them out of there a year
later because they're just dying but
those companies don't usually do that
because they just need to maximize and
it's if they're actually incentivized to
let you quit and like because then we're
gonna replace you for less and you know
so that's that so the question was yeah
it's normal because most of the most of
the companies are Vig din a game that
creates a scenario for high turnover and
so in general I'm trying to push you
guys 181 episodes deep have you've been
along the ride or if you're 20 episodes
then or if this is your first episode
the the concept of the show is to always
level up the thinking around business
and entrepreneurship this is an insight
to why it happens right everything stems
from the top always in forever I promise
you your manager who sucks crap the
fault of that situation is the CEO
always blaming the CEO cuz it's the CEOs
fault well question of the day do you
like your CEO you keep asking questions
I'll keep answering them
what's Andy doing what are you doing
trying to get some food with Alex what
you need a buddy to get lunch
[Music]